for nazar things are almost like home
when his mother
Irina gets him ready for play school but
nazar home is nearly a thousand
kilometres away
in eastern Ukraine in a warzone the
family has fled and his parents try to
hide the situation from him in vain he
hears us talking and he doesn't believe
us he asks one of the bad men going away
I want to go home and I say why do you
think there are bad men there and he
says I don't know so I say there aren't
any bad men while her son is in day care
Irina and her mother watch videos coming
from Ukraine they're glad they escaped
the violence in time more and more
refugees from the war in Ukraine are
coming to Moldova so far the country has
been able to take them in right
officials are expressing concern
mr. chief release toad a congratulatory
the numbers are very worrying
particularly when you look at the stuff
we have and the available accommodation
and the financial resources we have to
launch our empathy system on Karla
impoverished Moldova has a generous law
governing the rights of refugees people
fleeing war zones get the right to stay
modest financial support and most
importantly a work permit all within
months arenas husband Dima has found
work as an electrician together with
Moldova and colleagues he's laying
telephone lines in a new hotel the job
not only provides the income he
desperately needs but has made him feel
welcome in the country I feel quite
normal here among the Moldavians the
people are very friendly and I have not
experienced anyone insulting me or
treating me badly the way people in
Moldova see it there are old ties
linking the two countries they're still
close it's good that our country is
helping the Ukrainians that's wonderful
one fourth confirm purported that in the
Soviet era we were one country that's
why we Moldovans have to help the
Ukrainians help is essential because
Ukraine has be sent by war and
despotisms has taught us the qualified
engineer is afraid to reveal his
identity he was called up for the
Ukrainian military even though he had an
exemption he tells us it was torn up in
front of his eyes
nor is to sort of course I refused I
told them I wouldn't sign anything I
said I didn't want to go they lock me up
for four days and they beat me
I saw that I'd only get out of there if
I signed
he was taken home under police guard to
pack he managed to escape through the
window with nothing but his passport
friends helped him reach Moldova while
Dovan officials refused to acknowledge
him as a refugee because he doesn't come
from a war zone he has the help of a
lawyer he's told the authorities what
the Ukrainian police would do with him
and he's even showed them pictures of
what happened to another objector who
was deported from Moldova
good businessman sports I explained my
situation to them and they said they'd
investigate it now I'm waiting for the
answer
Moldovans are observing the situation in
Ukraine with concern in the early 1990s
Moldova experienced a similar kind of
conflict when the province of
Transnistria broke away with Russian
support today soldiers face off at the
border no one knows how long the peace
will hold there are fears that the
conflict could break out again I'm very
scared war is the worst thing there is
and I am afraid I don't think we will
have a conflict by that again
the politicians are moving in the right
direction Dima doesn't want to imagine
the war in Ukraine spilling over into
Moldova the family has managed to find
some normality here and they're clinging
to it where else could they go so they
talked about going back home do you
crane it's very very hard to leave your
town I don't want to be anywhere else
but home lots of students of the one the
longer the conflict in eastern Ukraine
goes on the more that dream recedes into
the distance